RADIO COMMUNICATION ALSO WENT
DEAD DURING THE FORT LAUDERDALE
AIRPORT SHOOTING IN 2017 THAT HE
ALSO GOT A LOT OF CRITICISM FOR.
I WANT TO START WITH YOU,
REPRESENTATIVE FEIN, YOUR
REACTION TO THIS NEWS THAT THEY
WERE TOLD TO ENTER WITHOUT BODY
CAMS, WHICH THEY LACKED AT THE
TIME, YOUR REACTION?
>> THANK YOU, LORD.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
THE MORE WE LEARN ABOUT THE
SITUATION, THE MORE OBVIOUS IT
IS THAT SHERIFF ISRAEL NEEDS TO
RESIGN OR BE REMOVED
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT IS WHY I SIGNED THAT
LETTER, AND THAT IS BY THE
FLORIDA HOUSE IS MOVING THIS
WEEK TO SUBPOENA ALL RECORDS OF
SHERIFF ISRAEL, AND WE ARE GOING
TO BE SUBPOENAING HIM AND MAKING
THEM COME TO TALLAHASSEE TO
EXPLAIN HIMSELF.
WHAT HAPPENED IS A DISGRACE.
>> Laura: MARK, I WANT TO GO
TO DO THIS.
THE REPORT WE GOT THAT SOME OF
THESE RADIO COMMUNICATIONS ARE
MISSING OR WEREN'T RECORDED
WHICH, I THINK, ARE VERY
IMPORTANT, ARE GOING TO BE
CRITICAL AS WE TRY TO DETERMINE
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED IN THE
AFTERMATH HERE.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE
HAVE LEARNED, FRANKLY, JUST
TODAY AND TONIGHT?
>> WELL, IT'S PRETTY SHOCKING
THAT, ONE, IT EVEN OCCURRED,
AND, TWO, WE WERE ABLE TO FIND
OUT ANY OF THIS INFORMATION.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS,
SHERIFF ISRAEL IS A CHARACTER,
HE IS A POLITICIAN.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT.
BUT IT REALLY HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE ACTIONS OF THE DEPUTIES
AT THE SCENE.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY HAD RADIOS.
I DON'T CARE IF THEY WERE ON OR
OFF.
THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE EXACTLY
WHAT THEY KNEW THEY HAD TO DO
REGARDLESS OF WHO TOLD THEM WHAT
TO DO OVER RADIO.
YOU IGNORE THAT AND YOU GO IN
AND TO TRY TO SAVE THE LIVES OF
THOSE CHILDREN AND YOU CONTACT
THE SHOOTER AND KILL HIM.
>> Laura: AND TERRY, LET'S GO
TO YOU.
WE ARE ALSO LEARNING THAT IN THE
TRAINING OF SOME OF THESE POLICE
OFFICERS, THEY WERE TAUGHT A
KIND OF -- 2D CONFLICT THE
SITUATION, DON'T RUSH IN, ASSESS
THE SITUATION FIRST, AND
SCOT PETERSON'S ATTORNEY IS
SAYING THAT AS WELL, WHICH HAD
TO GET HIM ON THE SHOW TONIGHT,
HE WOULD NOT JOIN US, WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE.
IF THE POLICE HAVE BEEN TRAINED
IN A WAY THAT IS NOT REALLY
HELPFUL IN THIS TYPE OF
SITUATION, THAT ALSO IS
SOMETHING WE'D BETTER FIND OUT
PAST.
>> LAURA, THAT IS AGAINST ANY
PROTOCOL THAT I HAVE BEEN AWARE
OF SINCE COLUMBINE.
ALL OF US IS THAT I AM AWARE OF
ARE ALWAYS TAUGHT TO GO IN --
DON'T BE STUPID, BUT GO IN
TACTICALLY BUT GO IN.
PROTECT THE INNOCENTS THERE.
IF THEY ARE BEING TRAINED THAT
WAY, I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY WOULD
BE TRAINED THAT WAY.
>> Laura: WELL, ONE OF THE
REPORTS WE ALSO HEARD, REP FEIN,
THE DEPUTY ON-SITE THOUGHT THAT
APPARENTLY SOME OF THE SHOOTING
WAS TAKING PLACE OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING.
AGAIN, RADIO TRANSMISSIONS, THAT
I THINK WE MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE,
INDICATED THAT SOMEONE WAS
INJURED ON OR NEAR THE FOOTBALL
FIELD.
AND SO THAT IS ONE OF THE
REASONS HE STAYED BEHIND THE
CEMENT BARRIER OR CAR AND WAS
JUST A DASH FOR GROUP MINUTES
WENT BY AND PEOPLE WERE BEING
SHOT ONE AFTER THE OTHER AFTER
THE OTHER IN THIS BUILDING.
MAYBE IT WAS JUST AN HONEST
MISTAKE?
IT SEEMS LIKE WE SHOULD HAVE A
LOT OF VIDEO ALREADY PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE.
>> YEAH, AND IF SHERIFF ISRAEL
WASN'T SO BUSY BLOVIATING ON CNN
TOWN HALLS, WE MIGHT HAVE SOME
OF THAT INFORMATION.
THAT IS WHY WE HAVE BEEN ASKED
TO SUPPORT HIM AND GETTING
SHERIFF ISRAEL TO RESIGN OR BE
REMOVED.
THAT SHOULD BE TO MAKE HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Laura: MARK FUHRMAN, THERE
IS A SOUND BITE THAT I THOUGHT
OF YOU WHEN I HEARD THIS
YESTERDAY.
I KNOW YOU KNOW WHICH ONE IT IS.
I'LL READ IT.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE IT READY.
JAKE TAPPER BASICALLY ASKED HIM
ABOUT THE BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S, YOU KNOW, REACTION,
IF THEY HAD DONE THINGS
DIFFERENTLY, WOULDN'T HAVE
HAPPENED OR NOT.
AND SHERIFF ISRAEL SAID, LISTEN,
IF IF'S IF SOUND BITES WERE
CANDY AND NUTS, O.J. SIMPSON
WOULD STILL BE
IN THE RECORD BOOKS.
AND JAKE TAPPER, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS, THERE WERE LOTS
OF THINGS HE COULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY.
HE HAD THIS GLIB WAY OF
RESPONDING, AND I THINK YOU HIT
THE NAIL IN THE HEAD.
HE IS MORE OF A POLITICIAN THAT
SOMEONE HAS A MAGIC THAT HAS THE
LARGEST POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
COUNTRY.
I DIDN'T REALIZE THAT IT IS THE
LARGEST POLICE DEPARTMENT IN THE
COUNTRY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW IT CAN BE
WITH NEW YORK AND SO FORTH.
OF ITS TYPE, I GUESS IT IS THE
LARGEST.
>> HE SEEMS AWFULLY IMPRESSED
WITH HIMSELF, ALMOST FLIP IT,
LIKE HE DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE SEE
THE GRAVITY OF WHAT HAPPENS,
LIKE IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SOMEONE TO KNOW HIS FIRST AND
LAST NAME AT ALL OF HIS CAREER.
BUT WHEN HE HAD TO, HE HAD TO
ACTUALLY GIVE UP THIS
INFORMATION ON THE DEPUTY THAT
WAS SITTING OUTSIDE OF THAT
BUILDING NUMBER 12 LISTENING TO
THE GUNSHOTS -- AND I'M GOING TO
TELL YOU RIGHT NOW, THEY KNEW
FULL WELL THAT SHOOTING WAS
GOING ON INSIDE OF THAT
BUILDING.
I WILL GUARANTEE SOMETHING FOR
DEPUTY PETERSON OR X DEPUTY
PETERSON.
HE WILL RELIVE THAT 4 MINUTES
OUTSIDE OF THAT BUILDING FOR THE
REST OF HIS LIFE.
>> Laura: THAT'S FOR SURE.
LET'S GO TO TERRY ON THIS.
SPEAKING OF THE NEED FOR A REAL
THOROUGH INVESTIGATION THAT IS
NOT TAINTED OR QUESTIONED, COULD
BE FBI OR COULD BE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, I SHOULD SAY, COULD
THEY CONDUCT A REAL
INVESTIGATION HERE GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THE FBI CLEARLY
DROPPED THE BALL ON AT LEAST TWO
OF THESE TIPS.
THE MOST RECENT ONE WAS REALLY
DISTURBING.
INVOLVING THE WOMAN WHO ACTUALLY
HAD HIM LIVING IN HER HOUSE?
COULD THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
REALLY DO THIS?
>> I BELIEVE THEY CAN, LAURA,
BUT THE PROBLEM HERE, THE FBI
HAS DROPPED THE BALL FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, AS I
MENTIONED TO A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES, THE FBI NO LONGER
COMMUNICATES WITH THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN YOU CONTACT THE FBI
ANYMORE, EVEN MYSELF AS A
RETIRED FBI AGENT, WHEN I CALLED
THE AGENCY I USED TO WORK OUT, I
GET A RECORDING.
I DON'T SPEAK TO A HUMAN BEING.
WHEN I WAS AN FBI AGENT, WE
ANSWER THE PHONE.
WE TALKED TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
WE WERE THERE TO PROVIDE SAFETY
TO THE COMMUNITY, AND IN ORDER
TO DO THAT, YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEM.
THEY HAVE TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
WITH YOU AS AN AGENT, A TRAINED
AGENT, NOT AS AN ANALYST, NOT AN
ANALYST, BUT A SPECIAL AGENT OF
THE FBI.
THE FBI HAS TRIED TO CENTRALIZE
ALL THEIR ACTIVITY FOR SO LONG
NOW THAT THEY HAVE LOST TOUCH
WITH THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT IS THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE.
WHETHER THE DOJ CAN INVESTIGATE
THAT AND COME UP WITH A
CONCLUSION, I'M CERTAIN THEY
CAN.
WITH THE FBI NEEDS TO WORK
WITHIN ITSELF AND IT NEEDS TO
START PROVIDING THE SERVICES TO
THE COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS FINDING
OUT THAT THIS 19-YEAR-OLD WAS
ASSESSED WITH ISIS, COMING TO
$25,000, BUYING ALL OF THESE
GUNS, TALKING ABOUT SHOOTING UP
SCHOOLS AND RIPPING ANIMALS
APART.
I MEAN, DING, DING, DING, THE
WARNING BELLS ARE COMING OFF,
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS I
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS N
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS H
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS S
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS G
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS T
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS ,
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS 2
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS /
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS 0
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS H
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS N
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS S
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS G
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS T
I'M NOT AN EXPERT, BUT I GUESS .
TO ME, THIS IS A WILD SITUATION.
BY DON'T YOU WRAP IT UP.
>> LAURA, ON THE FBI GOT THAT
TIP ON NICHOLAS CREW, -- NIKOLAS
CRUZ, IT'S PROBABLY VERY
SPECIFIC WAY, ALL THAT FBI AGENT
HAD TO DO WAS GO
TO A FEDERAL DATABASE FOR GUN
REGISTRATION AND JUST FIND OUT
IF HE NIKOLAS CRUZ HAD PURCHASED
ANY WEAPONS.
LO AND BEHOLD, IT WOULD HAVE
POPPED UP.
>> Laura: BINGO.
>> THE AR-15, MIKE PARKLAND,